I've got a magnet here big circular
magnet it's a ring shaped magnet rather
like the sellotape so it goes round this
is a tiny little compass needle it so
this seems to be pointing upwards it
moves across it goes horizontal and then
it goes downwards out the other side so
there's a magnetic field coming out I've
got another little magnet this is again
a ring magnet on the top you can see the
magnetic field is pointing upwards and
on the bottom it's going the other way
so now if I bring this downwards there's
a repulsion and you can feel as you
bring it down there's a repulsion
between these two it's as though I have
here really big magnet and what I want
to do is place this big magnet over the
center and if I get it over the center
you can see it will start to float
because of the repulsion between this
magnetic pole and the magnetic pole in
the base so as I lift this up it will
slide down and you won't so stay about
that height this is a really strong
magnet so it's probably 2 inches or more
above so now what I want to do is get
this to be floating above there and I
can't do that normally because it wants
to turn that way so I try and get it to
go there and it will fall down so the
trick is to spin it because if you spin
it it has a persistence it wants to stay
upright like a little spinning top so
the object is to take this thing and put
it in a space above there spinning round
so it doesn't fall down and you do that
in two steps the first step is to spin
it on here you see how it wants to repel
against there and of course I can go for
half an hour doing this take 57 eight
972 until I get one that works and then
I lift it up bit by bit to the point
where it just comes up and then it
starts to float in the air and if I got
this level it
stay there for a nice length of time
this is not held at home I should have
balanced it a bit better and it's more
or less level there I can pass a ring
through it either direction
nothing is supporting you our magic is
involved no animals were killed and
there it floats for about a minute and a
half and I don't know what to say that
will keep you amused for that length of
time it starts to process when it slows
down because of the friction of the air
the rotation rate goes down a little bit
so here it's spinning around maybe at 25
rotations per second and it slows down
it slows down bit by bit and you can
feel after a world that as it slows down
the direction it's pointing starts to
wiggle around a little bit and then
about 10 seconds after that it plummets
down to the ground well this is the
point where we find out whether this is
all a dream or not it's just wagging so
much that I'm short oh yes there it is
yeah it's a mixture of repulsion and
gyroscopic motion but the paper that
came out to explain door wood by Sir
Michael Barry who is one of the leading
theoretical physicists of his generation
and he loves all these toys he would go
and analyze him in gory detail the the
idea of having a magnet a rotating back
burner a spinning magnet has analogies
with protons and neutrons which would be
in traps or atomic particles which could
be in magnetic traps so it is used but
not quite in this toy light form I just
I found I'm dicted to this
you